anja merkel hat in hamburg ihre
abschiedsrede gehalten zum abschied hat
sie auch gesagt obwohl sie als kanzlerin
noch bleibt
parteivorsitzender hat sie sich hier
verabschiedet das erste
äußerlich bemerkenswerte
ist das hat sie gestern schon in den
gremiensitzungen angekündigt es ist eine
kurze rede hält die rede war nur eine
gute halbe stunde lang war sehr
konzentriert sie hat fünf punkte
aufgeschrieben fünf punkte vorgenommen
mit denen sie ihr verhältnis zur partei
beschrieben hat und vielleicht der
wichtigste ist dass sie kein gestanden
hat die partei habe etwas vermissen
können bei hier als sie zum ersten mal
als vorsitzender auf einem parteitag war
und das parteitagsmotto aber geheißen
zur sache habe sie eben nicht
deutschland erwähnt oder sicherheit oder
gestaltung und
sie hat heute verständnis dafür geäußert
dass ihre partei das bei hier vermisst
habe das ist ja auch vorgeworfen worden
dass sie zu wenig gestalterischen
anspruch hat zu wenig ihn viel reaktiv
ist zur sache geht eben nur und nicht
zum herz der emotion aber umgekehrt
dienen und euch so manchen richtig
deftigen scharfen angriff auf den
politischen gegner ob von links oder
rechts vorenthalten und stattdessen das
florett gewählt oder es vorgezogen zu
schweigen und gar nicht erst über das
stöckchen zu springen das man ihr
hinhält
ich weiß sehr wohl dass ich eure nerven
damit sehr auf die probe gestellt haben
diese form von ein geständnis
vielleicht der zentrale teil ihrer
halbstündigen rede gewesen
insofern war das eine verneigung vor
ihrer partei der sie gesagt hat die
partei habe ihr merkel nicht zugemutet
sie dafür habe aber der partei etwas
zugemutet weil sie weniger harte direkte
angriffe auf den politischen gegner
durchgeführt habe als die partei das
vielleicht kann hier erwartet habe sie
hat also ihre art politik zu machen
sachorientiert inhaltlich orientiert und
nicht zu emotionalisiert verteidigt sie
hat dafür fast zehn minuten beifall
bekommen
entstehen vorgetragenen weiß also wie
man das auch erwartet hat keine
jubelstürme
aber so etwas was sie ihrer art die
partei zu führen
fast einen langen wohl in meisten teilen
auch ehrlichen drei fall für eine arbeit
die eben im wesentlichen zur sache gehen
[Applaus]